we are now going to continue our study
of labor markets and in this video we're
going to focus on the demand curve for
labor so let's imagine that we're
talking about a market for
people who work in the pant making
industry so each of these firms right
over here they produce pants let's say
they produce bell bottoms so this is my
quick drawing of bell bottoms these are
someone's pants right over here they
flare out at the bottom and let's say
for some strange reason bell bottoms all
of a sudden go back in style
so bell bottoms are going back in style
the firm is at least in the short run is
able to get more per unit for its bell
bottom so its marginal revenue goes up
and if its marginal revenue goes up its
marginal revenue product is going to go
up and so
we would have a shift to the right of
the marginal revenue product curve or
you could even view that as a shift up
for a given quantity of labor you're
going to have a higher marginal revenue
product so this we could call this
marginal
revenue product
curve 2.
now what was likely to happen in the
market well if it's a general fashion
trend it's not just for this firm's
goods or or product but it's for
everyone all of the pant producers well
then they're all going to want a lot
more people who can work in the pant
producing industry or another way to
think about it is the market labor
demand curve is just a sum of the
marginal revenue product curves for all
of the various firms and if all of them
have shifted to the right or shifted up
well the same thing is going to happen
to the market labor demand curve and so
the market labor demand curve might now
look like this
so market
labor
demand
curve
sub 2. now what does that do to the
equilibrium wages and quantities well
our equilibrium wage has gone up which
seems reasonable because the demand
curve has shifted to the right and our
equilibrium quantity has also
gone up i'll put a q sub 2.
now what does that do to the marginal
factor cost for the firms operating in
this market the ones that are hiring
this labor
well the wages have gone up so so has
the marginal factor cost so in this
situation we now have a marginal factor
cost sub 2.
and now we have a new
quantity that is rational
for this firm to actually go out and
higher
and you can imagine things going the
other way so here we saw things shift
to the right both the marginal revenue
product curves and the market labor
demand curve but maybe things aren't
going well and the marginal revenue goes
down for these firms well then you can
imagine a situation where on the firm
level your marginal revenue product
curve shifts down and to the left maybe
it does something like that marginal
revenue product three and in aggregate
that would cause the market labor demand
curve to shift to the left and you would
see the opposite happen you would see a
lower equilibrium wage let me just label
this
market
labor
demand
curve
3
you would have a lower equilibrium wage
now
and you would have a lower quantity of
labor
equilibrium quantity of labor in that
market sub three and then you would have
a lower a lower
marginal factor cost assuming a
perfectly competitive labor market and
so this might be the equilibrium
quantity right over there q
for the firm sub 3 with a star once
again not counterintuitive this is what
we've seen in other
markets when we talked about what would
cause shifts in demand if the firms for
whatever reason are not able to get as
much incremental benefit per unit for
extra unit of labor well that's going to
shift things to the left both at the
firm level and at the market level and
if for some reason the firms are able to
get a lot more incremental benefit per
extra unit of labor well that's going to
shift both the marginal revenue product
at the firm level to the right and the
market labor demand curve at the market
level to the right